am I crazy am I just really stupid did I
have a massive stroke and hallucinate a
way better movie for two hours than
whatever on L saw in the heat of my
brain cells disappearing in mass I liked
the venom movie I kept waiting for the
part where it would turn terrible and
laughable but just never came but do you
even have that stupid scene where the
suit makes Eddie dance it's like all the
worst parts were edited out and the
final product was competent
not exactly a masterpiece but it's not a
mess like everyone saying please someone
just tell me I was hit in the head with
a stray baseball or something like I
don't know how to describe it I watched
the movie and thought some parts of it
were definitely finicky but everyone's
acting like it's Fantastic Four or
Catwoman or Green Lantern but it felt
more like I don't know kind of like
ant-man cuz ant-man was a small story
unintended with some neat and creative
action scenes and some characters I
liked a lot and a few issues here and
there that ultimately didn't detract
from my enjoyment it wasn't the Dark
Knight but it wasn't [ __ ] Catwoman
alright I know this is the big question
on everyone's minds so I'll get this out
of the way first what's wrong with it
well I can tell you pretty firmly that
it has flaws but you name 10 movies that
don't ya keep workin on that the biggest
things that stuck out to me were some
moments where the dialogue was really
clunky like here's a non spoiler one if
you saw the trailer after Eddy falls off
the motorcycle and breaks his legs the
bad guy catches up to him and he finally
transforms into venom and eats a guy's
head then he swims super far away
through the San Francisco Bay and when
he turns back to Eddy he immediately
goes my legs were broken and now they're
fine
Eddy you turned into an 11-foot monster
and ate a man's head I think you should
have commented on that first Jesus I
know you reporters are jaded but wowzer
it's a really weird line yeah does it
ruin the whole movie no it just made
that one scene feel a little weird but
the dialogue after it is fine there's a
lot of spots like that
but again they don't ruin the movie they
just feel a little stiff
even still Tom Hardy does a
good job of delivering his lines the
trailers made a map to sound like a
mental deficient who jump cuts nine
times every sentence but he sounded fine
to me
they even fixed Venom's overly bassy
voice another big gripe is the pacing
this movie starts off at a decent pace
develops everything about as well as it
should but as soon as Eddie gets the
suit it just bumps into overdrive and
barely slows down until the ending I
think the middle act of the film is
where you can feel the studio mandated
ed it's the hardest it just Sprint's
from one thing to the next and some
really important conversations are just
rushed in there really fast however
don't get me wrong this movie makes
sense it's not like Suicide Squad where
the hack editing job makes it feel like
a bunch of random scenes mash together
in no particular order
it's very coherent and fluid I never had
to stop and ask wait how did we get here
or wait when was that established
regarding some plot elements everything
you need is in there it's just going a
little too fast and of course the
soundtrack is a cringy mess of
incredibly dated songs and it distracts
from a pretty decent Original Score Tom
Hardy was certainly trying his best and
while everyone else is kind of not as
into it they aren't distractingly bad
Veneman eddie still feel exactly like
themselves from the books eddie is
high-strung has a very specific sense of
morality is a little morally flexible if
it gets the job done and is kind of a
goofball despite taking himself really
seriously venom is crazy violent in a
rambunctious little thing but sometimes
stops to smell the roses and appreciate
life on earth he has a sense of right
and wrong on his own and needs Eddie to
guide him away from chaos a little but
it's still good deep down it's like the
script somehow pulled a miracle out of
its ass and understood these characters
pretty well sure Eddie isn't religious
in this version and he's a lot less
angry all the time but he still feels
like himself reminds me a little bit
more of the recent dawn Kate's venom
book where he's like not as much of a
grumpy douchebag and when I hear people
criticize Venom's being a flat character
they always talk about how he's this big
dumb feral rage machine full of hate
they tone that part
and work more on his other traits and
yet I get this feeling that people will
somehow say that's still wrong anyway
I think everyone just decided to hate
this movie from the jump and really
wants to see something a lot worse than
what's there before I get into spoiler
territory take my word for it just put
all the behind the scenes nonsense out
of your head and go watch it anyway even
though you're probably seeing a shitload
of clickbait titles about it being trash
from people who have whatever opinion
will equal the most views just form your
own opinion give it a chance I really
love this character and well I think
there's plenty of flaws I still had a
great time and didn't come away
disappointed at all
alright now for some spoiler territory I
think the only noticeable parallel the
Catwoman is Eddie yells at an overly
loud neighbor in his apartment to turn
the music down while he's still figuring
out his powers now that's it I guess or
maybe the folks at cinema sins will make
some big point about how the main
character goes to a skyscraper or fights
police in both films and why that makes
it a nearly identical movie gotta love
them and they're totally honest opinions
however something I think was lacking a
little was the symbiotes motivation
venom seemed to have some kind of change
of heart somewhere in the film and best
I can guess is that it was a scene that
was on the cutting room floor at first
he's just kind of running around having
fun and fighting [ __ ] and then goes back
to Eddie and tells him he doesn't want
earth to be destroyed by riot and the
other symbiotes and it has this like you
changed me by being an okay dude moment
but that wasn't very well established
it just kind of stopped at one point to
tell Brock that it thinks are earth is
pretty and likes the food here but that
didn't really seem like enough for a big
character jump like there's just a scene
missing
I guess the middle act is missing a lot
of good stuff to really tie up the
characters however I still really like
the back-and-forth between Eddie and the
symbiote and they have a pretty fun
chemistry whenever they do get that time
to talk I feel like I saw 80% of a
really great venom movie
and they cut out a big chunk of the
stuff that would have made this go from
being just good to really great it's a
decent movie that was edited poorly and
that fits the description of a lot of
blockbusters lately from all the major
studios it's like the art of editing is
just dying but again this movie was
solid it told a story that made sense
and I like the characters and of course
the action was really unique and cool
I'll have to admit a certain amount of
bias though because I've read all the
venom comics some of the mechanics of
the symbiote are kind of glossed over
and not explained super explicitly some
people who don't know a lot about the
character might get a little confused
about some stuff but having all this
prior knowledge to the source material I
didn't feel the need to get answers for
those questions because I already knew
how it worked but again that's just a
minor thing if you want to understand
how the suit doesn't kill Eddie by
eating his organs just go read this
comic called venom the hunger it's
really good and the movie makes a nice
little nod to it near the end also Woody
Harrelson's wig look really stupid but
anyway I'd be down for a sequel of
carnage hell yeah dude huh I just can't
shake this feeling of guilt for enjoying
this movie so much I don't know why I
have this anxiety like I'm the only
person in the world who had a good time
watching this and now my credibility as
a reviewer is going to be in question
and people are gonna start making memes
about me being stupid for liking it I
just want crazy pills here like I feel
bad that everyone decided to hate this
movie from the trailers alone and it's
going to crash and burn I feel like Sony
actually kind of did right by me for
once after stabbing me in the heart a
few dozen times well there's two sad
outcomes to this either everyone
continues to hate on this because it
doesn't have that big special stamp on
the cover and a cameo from Tom Holland
or positive word of mouth spreads and
make people loosen up and give it a
chance only for it to be successful and
give Sony the wrong idea that they
should make that Morbius spin-off film
in their dumb cinematic universe without
spider-man I'd argue that venom is the
only spider-man character you can give a
solo movie it doesn't work for anyone
else because none of
them are interesting enough to even hold
their own comic without spider-man well
I get to accept the Punisher I guess
damn you Amy you put us in this
god-awful position and now we lose out
of way damn you but they reworked a lot
of this movie to accommodate a Spider
Man crossover in the future as a sequel
so if enough of you watch this movie you
may finally get what you want but with
that outcome we get a stupid cinematic
universe with Aunt May as a secret agent
I am willing to make that sacrifice are
you
[Music]
you